I'm back from my trip it's really me I'm
here and I'll talk about my trip on the
bonus show but sort of a bummer to have
to start my first show back with
something so disgusting and despicable
but this is the reality of what's going
on if you want to get a sense really an
actual real sense of where the Trump
administration is going militarily you
have only to look at Mike Pence's speech
over the weekend to West Point graduates
I'm going to show you a clip today which
cuts really to the heart of
neoconservative American right-wing
military aggression this is the worst of
the worst of the United States this is a
prime example of why so many around the
world are disgusted with us listen
closely to this one because it's not
getting the attention that it deserves
this is a from a speech that Mike Pence
gave over the weekend at West Point
which is a military academy it's one of
five u.s. service academies which are
undergraduate schools for commissioned
officers in the military in the case of
West Point when they graduate they have
an eight year commitment five years of
active duty and then three years in the
reserves and that's relevant for what
we're about to hear Mike Pence spoke to
the graduating class a few days ago and
effectively let slip that multiple wars
are in play and that graduates of West
Point should expect to be joining those
wars
Paul Waldman caught this and wrote it up
in the Washington Post and I went back
and looked at the transcript and it's
sickening take a listen to what Mike
Pence said it's a virtual certainty that
you will fight on a battlefield for
America at some point your life you will
lead soldiers in combat it will happen
some of you will join the fight against
radical Islamic terrorists in
Afghanistan and Iraq some of you will
join the fight on the Korean Peninsula
and in the indo-pacific where North
Korea continues to threaten the peace
and an increasingly militarized China
challenges our presence in the region
some of you will join the fight in
Europe where an aggressive Russia seeks
to redraw international boundaries by
force and some of you may even be called
upon to serve in this hemisphere and
when that day comes I know you will move
to the sound of the guns do your duty
and you will fight it will happen
Afghanistan and Iraq I thought we were
out of Afghanistan and Iraq other than
exploring what our presence might be
nevermind combat the Korean Peninsula
against North Korea or against a
militarized China what we should be
expecting that we're going to fight in
Europe Mike Pence is talking about
fighting in Europe this hemisphere which
to me means Latin America my mind goes
in the immediate to Venezuela but there
are other possibilities
and as Paul Waldman points out in the
Washington Post piece Pence is saying
not just that more Wars are inevitable
in some general sense he's talking about
their inevitability during the time that
these West Point graduates are going to
be either in active or reserve duty now
the defenders will say I know what
they're gonna come out and say David
pence isn't being specific pence isnt
predicting he's simply saying these are
commissioned officers who lead troops if
they are statistically likely to see
combat well that's not true it has not
been statistically likely that West
Point grads see combat and pence is not
speaking in generalities he's talking
about combat in Afghanistan and Iraq two
places were supposedly leaving into a
degree have left and the debate really
has been about should or shouldn't the
US have a presence there and what should
it look like and for how long Mike Pence
is talking about combat leading troops
in Iraq and Afghanistan this should be
front-page news
Pence is talking about the Korean
Peninsula and China
remember that Trump said we'll talk
about North Korea again today by the way
Trump said we won't need combat with
North Korea because Kim jong-un is such
a good guy and so trustworthy
and his sense of humor and his
intelligence and everything is just so
lovely and Trump trusts him despite the
continued missile launches which we will
get to
and yet Pence is saying you should
expect that inevitably some of you are
going to end up in a combat zone in the
Korean Peninsula maybe involving an
increasingly militarized China and then
Europe I mean your which we could do an
entire show on pence talking about that
as well so eight years it's an eight
year commitment for these graduates
after they finish up their four years at
West Point five years of active duty
three years in the reserves and Mike
Pence is saying it's very likely that in
those eight years they will see combat
in some combination of Iraq Afghanistan
China North Korea Europe and he says
this hemisphere I'm hearing Latin
America I'm hearing Venezuela maybe I
guess we could take a guess at where
else we're thinking of most Cuba could
be a possibility I don't know
pence is referring to this as if it is a
foregone conclusion and a mere
inevitability it's a question of where
will each of you end up rather than if
and this is part of the totally toxic
and destructive that this is military
industrial excuse me military industrial
complex
this is neoconservative American foreign
policy at its worst it's all of these
things that depend on and assume and are
fueled by the tacit acceptance that it's
just a matter of figuring out which Wars
we're going to get involved in or start
rather than actually evaluating whether
we should be involved in these sorts of
conflicts or engagements at all
extremely disturbing almost beyond words
and not reported widely which is why I'm
leading the show with it today today's
program is sponsored in part by our
friends over at Loch Ness crypto dot-com
the team is based in Boise Idaho and
they've made it their mission to help
just everyday people navigate the world
of cryptocurrency and they've been doing
it since 2012
they've actually been teaching a course
about cryptocurrency at the Boise State
computer science department for years
and they've taken that curriculum and
sort of packed it into an easy to digest
course that's now available to anybody
who wants it called the cryptocurrency
starter kit and this is the type of
thing that crypto has really been
lacking and it's one of the reasons we
we maybe haven't seen adoption of
currencies like Bitcoin and others on a
larger scale normal people who are not
tech experts need a step-by-step guide
that's easy to understand about how they
can get involved with cryptocurrency in
a way that is sort of safe and
manageable and that's what the
cryptocurrency starter kit provides it's
a five part video series which includes
how to safely obtain Kryptos where to
set up your accounts how to protect
those accounts from hackers importantly
how to move crypto into physical
hardware wallets and also how to just
prepare for the future of the space you
also get a free physical hardware wallet
it's sort of like a flash drive where
you can safely store your Bitcoin or
other Kryptos offline and you also get
one hour of one on one phone or Skype
mentoring with one of lochness Kryptos
experts they're the only company in the
crypto space that offers a service like
this and it all comes with the
cryptocurrency starter kit they have a
special offer specifically for the David
Pakman show audience if you click the
link under this video you'll get $200
off the cryptocurrency starter kit check
it out using the link down below